how's it going everybody it's warren
welcome back to my channel the cosmic
wonder and we have
a lot of new mcu news today disney has
announced a new event in which we may
get some disney plus information there's
some pretty big casting calls for some
upcoming disney plus shows and
filming has resumed for one of our most
anticipated
disney plus marvel shows so we have a
lot to talk about today so let's just
jump right in but first of course if
you're new be sure to subscribe so you
don't miss out on any of the latest mcu
news and this week's giveaway is a loki
funko pop just subscribe like the video
leave a comment down below
so to start it off let's talk about the
walt disney company announcing their
fourth
quarter 2020 full fiscal year earnings
webcast now we recently had one of these
meetings a couple of months ago for the
third quarter in which the disney ceo
announced that they were soon going to
be talking about their upcoming disney
plus shows and he said that they were
going to talk about them in disney's
investor day
well unfortunately they are no longer
going to be doing an
investor's day so the plan to get new
information about the disney plus shows
and investors day
is gone however hopefully they bring
some of that news and information that
they were going to talk about for these
disney plus shows to their fourth
quarter earnings report now as far as
what to expect there's a couple of
pieces of information that we really
want to know that we most likely will
get
one is how well mulan did on disney plus
premiere
access their video on demand service now
of course the reason that we want to
know this number is because of black
widow
how well mulan did on disney plus's
premier access will determine
if they want to take black widow down
the same route now in the third quarter
webcast is when they actually introduced
premier access so there's no doubt that
they're going to talk about mulan
because it's the first and right now
only thing they have on premiere access
and if mulan did well they're definitely
going to consider putting black widow on
premiere access as well
and disney's ceo basically already said
that he said that mulan
is going to be a test and if it goes
well they will consider doing other
movies the same way on premiere access
so hopefully we find out more
information on whether or not black
widow is leaning more towards video on
demand or it's still planning on
releasing in theaters because
unfortunately
it doesn't look like these big huge
movies are going to be going back to
theaters pretty soon regal cinema shut
down and yesterday
dc did a major shift in their movies
postponing a few of them and now
black adam doesn't even have a release
date so it's not looking insanely good
for movies releasing in theaters right
now at least anytime
soon so disney plus as premier access
may be the way to go and of course the
next thing that we hope to hear about
is the upcoming disney plus shows which
of course would include wanda vision the
falcon in the winter soldier the loki
series the hawkeye series
miss marvel she-hulk moon knight and for
the star wars fans the mandalorian and
possibly some kenobi news
now unfortunately i wouldn't expect a
new trailer or anything like that but
more along the lines of some production
updates and when they expect all of
these shows to actually launch
fortunately for us these disney plus
shows don't get delayed by theaters not
being open they get delayed by
production being postponed but it seems
like marvel studios and disney are
running full speed again
so hopefully we might get some sort of a
release schedule
and unfortunately we don't have to wait
that much longer for this quarter four
earnings report as it is scheduled for
november 12th of 2020
at 4 30 pm eastern time and 1 30 p.m
pacific standard time and then we have
some pretty crazy news about
the hawkeye series we have nine
different new
casting calls for the series and we
actually have the descriptions for the
characters as well that's listed on the
casting call and this is coming from
thedirect.com
and we'll just go through the different
characters the first casting call is for
a 20s to 40s male or female eastern
european
henchman speaks with an accent strong
supporting
reoccurring character and that character
has the code name of
misha the next character is going to be
a child character with the second
listing
titled bella the description reads
female
white 8 years old precautious daring and
confident with a sense of humor
the next casting call is for a character
called brady with the description of
male white nine years old energetic and
sweet
the next character is heather and the
description reads female
white midwestern 26 years old
smart and scrappy does what she needs to
in order to survive
the fifth casting is for a character
called rose and her description is quite
interesting and it reads
female 8 years old deaf indigenous
independent athletic and bright small
supporting
please note that the dialogue in the
edition scene can be spoken in english
or
signed in american sign language if the
actor knows that language
the next character is titled richard and
is a 40 to 50 year old male
indigenous american a loving father and
fierce protector the seventh casting
call is for a person named mary and the
description is female
late 30s to early 40s open ethnicity
highly professional and ambitious career
woman
no nonsense and a reoccurring character
the eighth casting call is pretty
interesting as it's named
detective sherman who will have a rio
crane role in the series the description
is 40s male open ethnicity new york city
detective
reoccurring character and the ninth one
is called
alex and it's described as a female or
male
30 to 50 years old a sincere but funny
oddball with an obsession
for the fantasy sci-fi genre
so the hawkeye disney plus series is
right now casting for
a bunch of different people now based
off of some of these descriptions we can
kind of guess
on what some of these characters are
going to be in the series and some of
them are pretty vague
misha seems to be a member of the
tracksuit mafia which has been rumored
for a very long time now to be appearing
in the hawkeye series
heather bella and brady are all kind of
similar they're relative in age and
in terms of race indicating that they
are probably part of the same family one
that might be close to hawkeye in the
series
and then there's rose who is going to be
a deaf character in the series which
means that she'll probably have some
sort of a connection to
ekko ekko is another deaf superhero who
has been confirmed to be appearing in
the series
and then there are some indigenous
characters which could be a connection
to
the occupy avengers this is a group that
hawkeye formed with other native
american heroes such as
red wolf and nightshade and with the
indigenous character description we
could be seeing this group in the
hawkeye series
now unfortunately murphy's
multiverse.com today did state that the
hawkeye series production has been
delayed but the fortunate news is it's
only been delayed a month
it was originally planned for october
but now it's set for november so this
most likely isn't due to kovid it's most
likely due to something else within the
studio which is good news
that means we really shouldn't see any
further delays with the hawkeye series
especially with everything else starting
back up
and that leads us to our final piece of
news which is about the falcon and the
winter soldier
the falcon and the winter soldier crew
has now returned to prague to finish
their filming and this comes from the
facebook page of
fendimefilmu who says that they have
spotted the stunt teams on the set
so falcon in the winter soldier is back
filming in prague but unfortunately we
still aren't going to get this series
until 2021
so a lot happening with marvel studios
right now which is a really really good
thing
kovid isn't slowing them down anymore
and hopefully we won't really get any
more changes to marvel's phase 4
schedule and again that's the great
thing with all of these disney plus
shows kovid really doesn't affect the
release of them it only affects the
production
but right now everything is in
production or starting production
very soon so lots of marvel content
coming very
very soon so let me know how excited you
are for this in the comments down below
and let me know which disney plus series
you're excited for the most
don't forget to like the video and
subscribe so you don't miss out on any
of the latest mcu news for live
updates you can follow me on twitter and
instagram and as always thank you all so
much for watching
woof